Empecemos con una pregunta: ¿puede la guerra
en Ucrania provocar una hambruna en África?
Ya sé lo que muchos estaréis pensando: Rusia
y Ucrania están aquí los países de África
en esta gran masa de tierra
Pero, la realidad, queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik, es que la guerra ha puesto
patas arriba al mundo. Ya os hemos contado en
un montón de vídeos cómo ha llegado a convertir
los mercados energéticos en un enorme caos. Sin
embargo, esa no está siendo su única consecuencia.
La guerra en Ucrania también está poniendo contra
las cuerdas otro importantísimo
mercado, el mercado agrícola.
Pensadlo bien, es muy difícil vivir sin petróleo,
sin gas, o con los precios de estos hidrocarburos
disparados, sin embargo, vivir sin trigo o sin
maíz tampoco resulta mucho más fácil. De hecho,
para millones y millones de personas, la
falta de estos alimentos puede suponer la
diferencia entre comer o pasar hambre.
Y diréis: vale, pero… ¿Qué tienen que
ver Rusia y Ucrania en todo esto? Pues
más de lo que os imagináis. Básicamente,
porque estamos hablando de dos de los mayores
productores agrícolas de todo el mundo.
Seguro, seguro, muchos de los que nos estáis
viendo desde Europa, desde Estados Unidos o,
incluso, desde América Latina habéis notado
que los precios de la comida han subido
y mucho durante el último año. Pues ya sabéis
cuál está siendo uno los grandes motivos.
Sin duda está siendo duro, pero, por fortuna,
en general en esta parte del mundo no nos
estamos muriendo de hambre. Sin embargo,
hay un lugar del mundo del que no se puede
decir lo mismo: el África subsahariana.
Ya os hemos contado muchas veces aquí,
en VisualPolitik, cómo en el mundo y
particularmente en el África subsahariana,
se han conseguido tantos avances en los últimos
años que para muchos las hambrunas estaban
condenadas a no ser más que malos capítulos en los
libros de historia. Y de hecho, el hambre parecía
haber entrado en un camino hacía la extinción.
Algo en lo que los sectores agrícolas de Rusia
y Ucrania han sido claves. Para que os
hagáis una idea, Ucrania producía cada año
alimentos para 400 millones de personas,
muchas de ellas del África Subsahariana.
Pero ahora la guerra lo ha complicado todo. Las
exportaciones de grano desde Ucrania y Rusia ya
no son tan cuantiosas ni frecuentes como lo eran
antes de que Putin lanzará sus tropas sobre su
país vecino. Y por supuesto, esto ha hecho que
la tensión en los mercados agrícolas se dispare.
Y no solo porque los puertos ucranianos del mar
Negro estén en el punto de mira constante de Rusia
o porque los combates hayan limitado la producción
de Ucrania, si no es que incluso las sanciones a
Rusia hacen que ahora sus exportaciones
sean mucho más difíciles y más caras.
¿El resultado? La posibilidad de que se produzca
una crisis alimentaria salvaje no había sido
tan alta desde los años 80.
Entonces, la pregunta es:
¿qué iniciativas se están impulsando para
evitar una hambruna catastrófica? ¿Por qué
vendían Rusia y Ucrania tanto trigo a África?
Y otras dos preguntas que pueden sorprenderte
aún más: ¿Qué pinta Turquía en toda esta
historia? ¿Puede Turquía conseguir evitar
una hambruna en todo el mundo? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1( TECNOLOGÍA, PRODUCCIÓN Y TRABAJO DURO)
Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik,
recordaréis que una de las cosas que hemos
repetido hasta la saciedad en este canal es que
el número de personas que sufren la pobreza y
que pasan hambre ha estado cEayendo en picado
en todo el mundo durante las últimas décadas.
En lo que llevamos de siglo el hambre extrema
dejo de ser algo habitual. Y eso se debe sobre
todo a una razón: los avances tecnológicos.
Y, ojo, porque si os preguntara que sector
económico se ha desarrollado más en las últimas
décadas, seguro, seguro que la mayoría pensaríais
automáticamente en la industria, la informática o
cosas por el estilo. ¿Me equivoco? Seguro que no.
Y en cierto modo tenéis razón… Pero,
¿sabéis qué? La evolución del sector
agrícola no está siendo menos impresionante. Para
que os hagáis una idea, a principios del siglo XX,
en Europa o en Estados Unidos, todavía nos
podíamos encontrar con imágenes como esta:
Sin embargo, hoy en día los campos de los países
más desarrollados se parecen cada vez más esto:
Exacta, cada vez es más frecuente ver como
tractores sin conductor, robots de regadío,
drones y muchísimos otros avances tecnológicos,
permiten producir cada año muchos más alimentos.
Y todo eso por no hablar de los alimentos
genéticamente modificados. Lo cierto es
que en las próximas décadas puede que veamos un
enorme crecimiento de la producción alimentaria.
Un salto que ya hemos experimentamos hace
unas pocas décadas. Entre los años 60 y 80
se produjo un vuelco de 180º en los mercados
agrícolas. Por supuesto, os estoy hablando
de la conocida como Revolución Verde.
(La Revolución Verde no fue otra cosa
que un gigantesco aumento de la productividad de
la agricultura a nivel global. Empezó en México y
en Estados Unidos a finales de los años 50 con
la revolución del trigo, y poco a poco se fue
extendiendo por todo el mundo. El aumento de
la productividad se produjo gracias al uso de
nuevas tecnologías, la siembra de cereales
resistentes a los climas y las plagas más
extremas y el uso de fertilizantes sintéticos y
plaguicidas. De esta forma, los países de América
Latina y de toda Asia, como México, Pakistán o
la India, lograron multiplicar su producción.)
Otro caso muy conocido fue el de China,
un país dónde la revolución verde,
junto a las reformas promercado puestas en
marcha por Deng Xiaoping, logró reducir los
niveles de hambruna a mínimos históricos.
Podríamos decir que la Revolución Verde dejó
temblando hasta al más fiel maltusiano,
ya que probó claramente que el aumento
de la producción es totalmente compatible
con el aumento de la población y que el
hambre en el mundo se podía erradicar.
Y no solo eso, también confirmó otra
tendencia que hoy ya es más que evidente:
que una mayor producción no significa
más gente trabajando en la agricultura.
De hecho, como podéis ver, cada vez trabajan
menos personas en el campo, y al mismo
tiempo la producción es cada vez mayor.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento, porque
no todo el proceso tuvo tanto éxito.
El África Subsahariana fue la única
región del mundo que no se pudo unir
con éxito a la Revolución Verde.
¿Por qué? Pues por varias razones.
La primera y quizás más importante es
que, mientras el resto de países estaban
ya independizados durante la Revolución
Verde, muchos de los países del África
subsahariana estaban aún luchando por liberarse.
Y, cuando lo consiguieron, las luchas internas
por el poder y los gobiernos corruptos comenzaron
a florecer, haciendo prácticamente imposible el
desarrollo de proyectos de infraestructura que
permitieran incrementar la producción y luego
transportarla de un lado a otro. Por supuesto,
la inversión y el desarrollo de la agricultura
necesitan suficientes infraestructuras como poder
para poder exportar rápidamente su producción.
Y no solo eso, por ejemplo, esta también
es una de las razones por las que el uso de
fertilizantes es tan reducido en la región, porque
los costes de transporte son mucho más elevados.
Y si a todo esto le unimos que las condiciones
climáticas son extremas en muchas zonas del África
subsahariana, entonces tenemos el cóctel
perfecto para explicar el subdesarrollo
que vive este sector en la región.
Esto es precisamente lo que explica,
en buena medida, por qué aquí la agricultura
de subsistencia sigue estando a la orden
del día y por qué muchos de los países de la
región tienen que importar tantos alimentos.
Y como encima la población no para de crecer…
Pues el problema está servido. La demanda para
importar alimentos es cada vez es mayor.
Y claro, con semejante panorama,
la guerra de Ucrania ha sido con un misil
estallando en la mismísima línea de flotación.
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, este es
exactamente el principal motivo por el que la
guerra de Ucrania se ha convertido en toda una
enorme pesadilla para el continente olvidado.
Atentos.
T2(INNOVACIÓN FINANCIERA CONTRA LAS HAMBRUNAS)
¿Os acordáis de los activistas antiglobalización?
A principios del siglo XXI teníamos a muchas
personas diciendo cosas como que la globalización
financiera iba a destruir por completo al Tercer
Mundo y que las diferencias entre países ricos
y pobres aumentarían de manera catastrófica.
Pues bien, nada más lejos de la realidad.
En este vídeo ya os hemos contado cómo
la evolución tecnológica ha multiplicado la
producción agrícola hasta el punto de reducir
drásticamente las hambrunas en todo el m undo.
Pero lo que todavía no os hemos contado es
como las innovaciones financieras también han
ayudado a acabar con el hambre en el mundo.
Hablamos concretamente del conocido
como “mercado de futuros agrícola”.
Y os preguntaréis, ¿qué son estos mercados? Pues,
básicamente, son mercados donde se pueden comprar
y vender, muy fácilmente, los productos agrícolas,
como el trigo o el maíz, sin tener que estar
moviéndolos todo el rato. Son instrumentos que
permiten garantizarte el suministro de alimentos
en el futuro. Por eso se llaman futuros.
Claro que estos mercados no son algo
estrictamente nuevos, ni mucho menos. Llevan entre
nosotros mucho más de lo que os podéis imaginar.
(El primer mercado de futuros agrícola
se registró en Estados Unidos, en 1848,
fue el Chicago Board of Trade. Pero no fue hasta
los años 60 y 70 cuando podemos hablar de un
verdadero mercado global y totalmente abierto
en el que comprar y vender productos agrícolas.
Como las producciones podían venderse de antemano,
crecieron las inversiones en el sector y con
ellas las exportaciones agrícolas se dispararon)
Y así nació un nuevo mercado global. Gracias a
él, los países en vías de desarrollo que tienen
más dificultad para producir sus propios
alimentos, pudieron acceder a un montón de
nuevos alimentos mucho más baratos. En otras
palabras, los países del África subsahariana
que no pudieron engancharse a la Revolución
Verde pudieron suplir su escasez productiva
con las compras en el mercado internacional. Y eso
contribuyó decisivamente a reducir las hambrunas.
¡Ojo! Esto no significa que hayan desaparecido
ahí tenemos sin ir más lejos la dramática
hambruna por la que está pasando Somalia
como resultado de una dura sequía y que
ha acabado ya con más de 43.000 vidas.
Por otro lado, que estos países dependan
de las importaciones del trigo los hace
también más vulnerables a las propias
fluctuaciones del mercado internacional. Lo
vimos ya en la crisis financiera del 2008,
que provocó una crisis alimentaria, y lo volvimos
a ver en 2020 con la crisis del Covid-19 y el
colapso de las cadenas de suministro.
Pero ahora la situación es aún más
dramática. Echad un vistazo a cuáles son los
principales exportadores de grano del mundo:
Exacto, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Rusia es el principal exportador de grano
del mundo y Ucrania el quinto mayor.
Y ni siquiera hablamos solo de granos,
también son enormes exportadores de otros muchos
productos. Ahí está el caso del aceite de girasol,
del que Ucrania tenía una cuota de
mercado a nivel mundial del 46%.
Sus tierras negras, muy ricas en nutrientes
junto a las reformas desde la caída de la
Unión Soviética, han hecho que estos
dos países aumenten su producción
agrícola hasta el punto de convertirse en los
graneros de buena parte Europa y del mundo.
Sin ir más lejos, países como Benín,
Tanzania y el Congo importan más
del 70% de su grano desde Rusia.
Precisamente por eso, la guerra sin
cuartel que ahora enfrenta a Rusia con Ucrania
ha hecho saltar todas las alarmas. Los precios
se han disparado y la inseguridad alimentaria
se ha vuelto a convertir en un tema de moda.
La pregunta, entonces, es, ¿qué se está haciendo
para evitar otra catástrofe humanitaria en el
África subsahariana? ¿Cómo se está intentando
domar los precios? Pues bien, veámoslo.
T3(Y TURQUÍA… ¿QUÉ PINTA AQUÍ?)
Ya os hemos contado que Ucrania era,
y sigue siendo, uno de los mayores
productores de grano del mundo. Sin ir más
lejos, el el 72% de toda su población rural
trabaja en la agricultura. Pero la guerra
ha resultado devastadora para este mercado:
entre los bombardeos, el reclutamiento forzoso
y el dominio naval de Rusia en el mar Negro,
los costes de producción han aumentado como
la espuma. Además, se estima que el 25% de
todos los hogares ucranianos que vivían
del agro han suspendido sus actividades.
Ahora bien, no solo Ucrania tiene problemas.
Rusia tampoco se libra. Es cierto, los países
occidentales no impusieron sanciones contra
su sector agrícola, y en principio deberían
tenerlo mucho más fácil para exportar al resto
del mundo, dado que dominan el mar Negro.
Sin embargo, las sanciones están afectándoles
indirectamente. Al estar excluidos de los
sistemas de pagos internacionales, tener su
logística sancionada y negarse las aseguradoras
a trabajar con los cargamentos rusos, su sector
agrícola se está resintiendo como el ucraniano.
Seguro que ahora podéis
entendere un gráfico como este.
Sí, esto es lo que explica que
cuando bajaba a la panadería,
la barra de pan en lugar de costarme
70 céntimos paso a valer casi un euro.
Obviamente, no solo se trata del pan… Si no
también de la hmayor parte de la cesta de
alimentos. Y, claro, lo que es una subida de
precios incómoda en Europa o Estados Unidos,
en regiones como el África subsahariana, puede
suponer la diferencia entre comer o pasar hambre.
Y por eso, la comunidad internacional empezó
a reclamar cambios para evitar una catástrofe
alimentaria. ¿Y sabéis qué? Aquí es cuando
nuestra vieja amiga, Turquía, entra en escena.
(El papel de Turquía en la guerra desatada
por Rusia ha sido, cuanto menos, ambivalente:
no ha sancionado a Rusia, pero
tampoco le ha prestado su apoyo,
ya que es miembro de la OTAN. E incluso el país
ha suministrado armas al ejército ucraniano.
Pero más allá de eso, lo cierto es que
en términos generales ha buscado jugar
un papel de cierta neutralidad. Turquía ha
aprovechado este conflicto para mover ficha
en el tablero internacional e intentar granjearse
una mayor simpatía internacional al presentarse
como el mediador entre ambos países.
Y claro, estando en el mar Negro y
teniendo el control del estrecho del Bósforo,
Turquía ha jugado un papel clave a la hora de
intentar restablecer las exportaciones
de grano desde el mar Negro. De hecho,
junto con las Naciones Unidas, ha sido el
precursor de una iniciativa crucial para
reducir los precios del grano mundiales:
la Iniciativa de Granos del Mar Negro.)
Y, ¿en qué consiste esta iniciativa? Pues,
muy simple: Rusia no bombardea los barcos
ucranianos que lleven grano desde el mar
Negro, Ucrania habilita tres puertos para
llevar a cabo sus exportaciones, el de
Odesa, el de Chornomorsk y el de Yuzhne;
y Turquía revisa todas las embarcaciones y
los cargamentos en Estambul cuando entran y
salen los barcos ucranianos para evitar
que, por ejemplo, transporten armas.
Suena bien, ¿verdad? Pues hay que reconocer
que la Iniciativa ha tenido bastante éxito.
Como podéis ver, los precios tanto del trigo
como del maíz han estado cayendo desde que se
firmó la iniciativa. Sin embargo, se han
producido momentos de mucha incertidumbre
porque a veces Rusia ha dado la sensación
de querer romper este acuerdo… Lo que ha
hecho que cada dos por tres repunten los precios.
Y es que Moscú está jugando con esta iniciativa.
Intentan utilizarla para conseguir
que algunas sanciones se suavicen.
De esta forma, por ejemplo, cuando firmó su
participación en julio de 2022 lo hizo por 4
meses, y en noviembre, cuando renovó,
también, pero justo el 18 de marzo,
cuando tenía que renovarlo, lo hizo solo por
60 días. ¿Por qué? Porque quiere apretarles
las tuercas a los países occidentales.
Y no solo eso. Rusia quiere explotar
intensamente esta posición. Fijaos.
C1(“Si finalmente decidimos no prorrogar el
acuerdo dentro de sesenta días, estamos dispuestos
a suministrar desde Rusia gratuitamente a estos
países todo el volumen enviado durante el último
tiempo a los países africanos que lo necesiten
especialmente” – V. Putin (Marzo de 2023).
No podremos estar seguros de que esto vaya
a ser así hasta que Rusia decida retirarse de
la Iniciativa, si es que al final se retira.
Pero eso de dar algo gratis… no sé, no
parece demasiado ruso. Siempre hay algo a
cambio.
Ya os hemos
contado la estrategia de Rusia en África, y
como el grupo de mercenarios rusos Wagner, muy
vinculado a Kremlin, no presta sus servicios de
manera altruista: el oro siempre va por delante.
Pero incluso aunque estuviera dispuesto a hacerlo,
es muy difícil, por no decir imposible que logrará
reemplazar la producción ucraniana. Por eso,
esta Iniciativa es crucial para todas las partes:
no solo para que los precios bajen en los
mercados internacionales, sino también para
evitar una nueva catástrofe alimentaria
en las regiones más vulnerables, como es
precisamente el caso del África subsahariana.
El problema es que tener a Rusia jugando con los
plazos de ampliación de su participación no solo
genera una gran incertidumbre en los mercados,
sino también en el día a día de cientos
de millones de personas. De momento estas
son las expectativas para 2023 en un
mercado que ya está muy presionado:
C2(La cosecha mundial de cereal caerá un 2,2 %
en la campaña 2022-2023, según EEUU. EFEAGRO)
Agarraos que vienen curvas. Pero llegados
hasta aquí, la pregunta es para ti:
​​ ¿Creéis que Rusia romperá su participación en
la Iniciativa del Grano? ¿Volveremos a presenciar
otra crisis alimentaria de grandes dimensiones?
¿Qué soluciones creéis que podrían ser viables
para aliviar la situación? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.